brossard célèbre son cinquième
anniversaire de l'ocs est adapté cinq
années depuis que ce papa de deux
enfants autistes hacker s'approprier je
compte énormément de qu'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui parce que si ça fait
vraiment un beau me cohérent diakhaté
cris harakat équipe et on frôle les 80
le hockey d'apt et se développe nouveaux
chandails nouvelles couleurs les jeunes
de 6 à 17 ans dont le trouble du spectre
de l'autisme ne les a pas empêché
d'apprécier le vide
ok y'a guidés par leurs parents vers
l'aréna ces jeunes apprennent à sortir
de leur coquille ça n'a pas un peu salée
il fait changer aussi l'habitude d'aller
à l'école pc y avait beaucoup de
l'anxiété ou si je trouve très plat à
chaque dimanche je me lève toujours et
booth en énergie en avons un beau grand
joie leur qui aujourd'hui vicky
jolicoeur a cinglé acquis adapté et son
bonheur cette maman le trouve aussi
auprès des parents de ces enfants
certains enfants des troubles de langage
depuis qu'ils ont été créés leur
qu'adapter parle davantage parce qu'ils
arrivent à l'école lyon un chandail de
hockey
toutes ces petites victoires louis les
parents ne le partagent que pour nous là
c'est la paix se plaisait c'est pour ça
qu'on fait si
à la patinoire les jeunes s'amusent les
parents se libère l'esprit et il y a les
grands parents comme l'humoriste pierre
légaré
on oublie souvent d'en jouer au hockey
le mot s'est joué au hockey
j'ai fait ce que mon groupe a pas dit il
et j'ai marqué beaucoup de buts
oui j'ai eu un peu peur courage ses
petits fils mais ils admirent sur tout
le travail accompli par tous ces parents
bénévoles
ces enfants là en 4 secondes ils y ont
décidé que il pouvait être pas et
confiance
et quant à un moment donné ça se
manifeste pas levé pour rien mais aussi
québec reconnaît dorénavant leur
qu'adapter comme l'une de ses divisions
même titre que des niveaux atome pee-wee
bantam
c'est certain que pour les années à
venir on envisage des petits airs qui
adapte et qui vont se développer
comment le match se déroule en ce moment
et on voit bien les champs clés de
l'équipe pourra font vives coiffés début
donc ils vont hilton des synthés giffoni
jeu de passes télé de défense more
heroes qui adapte et on ne compte pas
les vues du monde et champions
l'adversaire est comme un partenaire
tout ce que sa perte a pas une personne
qui vont s'inverser sur rail pour un
jour il n'y avait pas ça pour compter
les voix 5 1
[Musique]
jean françois poirier radio canada